do
good morning everyone it is a good
morning
it's a good morning we're getting
prepared to celebrate independence day
today's job news uh brought us uh
something else to celebrate this morning
we learned that
in june our economy created
850 000 jobs eight hundred fifty
thousand jobs
wages went up for american workers since
it took office
our recoveries created an average six
hundred thousand dollar
sixty dollars i wish they'd probably
wish those six hundred thousand jobs
paid six hundred thousand dollars a year
but six hundred thousand jobs per month
we've now created over three million
jobs since it took office
more jobs than have ever been created in
the first five months of any presidency
in modern history
thanks to the incredible work of the
entire team
this is historic progress pulling our
economy out of the worst crisis in a
hundred years
driven in part by our dramatic progress
in vaccinating our nation
and beating back the pandemic as well as
other elements of the american rescue
plan
today the u.s is the only major
advanced economy where the oecd
projections of future output are higher
today
than they were in january 2020 before
the pandemic hit
and america was ranked first in
bloomberg's covert resilience ranking
none of this happened by accident
again it's a direct result of the
american rescue plan
and at the time people questioned
whether or not we should do that even
though we didn't have bipartisan support
well it worked in february the
congressional budget office projected
2021 economic growth would be 3.7
percent
yesterday they doubled that number to
7.4 percent in large part
thanks to the american rescue plan on
our work to defeat the virus
the last time the economy grew at this
rate was in 1984
and ronald reagan was telling us it's
morning in america
well it's getting close to afternoon
here the sun is coming out
at the time the cbo revised their long
run deficit projections down as a share
of gdp
they just have done so the american
rescue plan is strengthening our
financial position
and it grows our economy it's continuing
to grow our economy
and the strength of our recovery is
helping us flip the script
instead of workers competing with each
other for jobs that are scarce
employers are competing with each other
to attract workers
that kind of competition in the market
doesn't just give workers more ability
to earn higher wages
it also gives them the power to demand
to be treated with dignity and respect
in the workplace
more jobs better wages that's a good
combination
put simply our economy is on the move
and we have covert 19 on the run yes we
have more work to do
to get america vaccinated and everyone
back to work
we're aiming for full employment and
that means keeping our pace on jobs
growth including for black hispanic and
asian workers
but this progress is testament to our
commitment to grow this economy
from the bottom up and the middle out
the american rescue plan provided
resources to get shots in people's arms
and checks in people's pockets schools
schools were struggling to reopen so we
made vaccinating teachers a priority
getting schools of much needed support
in march
we've added just in the month of march
we added 364 thousand
education jobs and roles small
businesses and restaurants are getting
crushed
now we're delivering the loans and
support they need to reopen and to stay
open
this morning we've learned that jobs in
some hard hit sectors such as
restaurants hotels
amusement parks were up by 343
000 last month over 1.5 million in the
past five months
and more help is on the way to give
families
just a little bit more breathing room
starting this month families are going
to receive one of the largest ever
single year tax cuts that middle class
families have ever
received and it's called the child care
tax credit
and here's how it works in the past if
you pay taxes and had your good income
you could deduct two thousand dollars
per child
and that would come off the total amount
of taxes you owed you had two children
you know ten thousand dollars you take
off four thousand dollars in the
american rescue plan
we expanded that now
a a parent will get 3 600
for each child under the age of six and
three thousand dollars for dependents
they have between the ages of 6 and 17.
so instead of just being a credit
against the taxes you owe
it's now a fully refundable credit half
of which will get paid out
in monthly basis look what that means is
this year
middle class families with two young
children can expect to get
receive a seven thousand two hundred
dollars
in a rebate in effect a tax return
with the monthly payments of six hundred
dollars a month starting this month
until it's paid out
eight out of every 10 families
who use direct deposit will get their
refunds
they'll be able to get a monthly payment
on the 15th of every month from now to
the end of the year
so they get that paid out help
with families most needed most need help
to make ends meet
it's important i've said for a long time
it's time to give ordinary folks
ordinary americans
middle class and working class americans
a tax break
this is the type of tax cut that can
help our economy
because we'll go to families who are
going to spend it
it'll also help lead historic reduction
in child poverty
excuse me
historic reduction in child poverty
which will have long-term benefits for
our economy
and we're delivering 39 billion dollars
to help child care providers
serve more families to help parents
particularly women
get back to work last month our economy
added nearly 25
000 child care jobs again
none of this happened by accident we're
providing
proving to the naysayers and the
doubters that they were wrong
none of this is guaranteed to continue
though unless we finish our work
now is the time to accelerate the
progress we've been making
now is the time to build in long-term
foundation that we've laid and build it
in for a long term
economists of all stripes agree that my
plan will create good jobs
drastically strengthen our economy in
the long run so we have to continue to
make the investments that will allow our
economy to build back
better and deal everyone in
we took a significant step in that
direction last week
when the bipartisan group of senators
forged an agreement with me to move
forward
on key portions of my american jobs plan
it was i was just in wisconsin where i
highlighted how this agreement is going
to pave the way for a generational
investment
to modernize our infrastructure create
millions of jobs according to the
experts
and what will mean and ever and
won't just be in the center cities it'll
be every corner of the state
and our nation we're going to create
jobs repairing roads and bridges
replacing 100 of our nation's lead
water pipes making our power grid more
reliable
delivering high-speed internet to every
american home
rural and urban we're going to put
people to work building a nationwide
electric vehicle charging network
transitioning from diesel school buses
and transit buses
to electric buses and bringing in
world-class
rail service to more americans by
reducing and in the process reduce our
carbon footprint for example
when i was up in wisconsin i said i
pointed out the governor was i said gov
i know it takes there are i don't know
how many people
a couple hundred people i guess in the
audience said it takes they tell me four
and a half hours to drive from here to
chicago
with the money we have and for mass
transit here
we you're going to be able to do that in
two and a half hours
and all the data shows that when it's
easier to get someplace
by rail than by automobile it's cheaper
and it generates a whole lot less carbon
footprint
we're going to create good paying union
jobs capping hundreds of thousands of
abandoned oil
and gas wells to stop methane leaks
which are devastating
and to protect the health of our
communities these are good jobs
taken together these investments are
going to position america to compete
with the world
and win the 21st century
you know as you bring home key parts of
my american jobs plan
i'm going to make the case for uh
equally critical investments that we
still need including those with in which
i
introduced at the same time my americans
family plan
when i was running for president i put
together a bold aggressive plan to
deliver child care
paid leave universal pre-k for three and
four-year-olds
free community college maybe the most
important thing among them was extending
the child care tax credit i just
mentioned
for another five years which will
significantly benefit middle class and
working class families
that human infrastructure is as
essential as our physical infrastructure
it can help us create more good jobs
ease the burden on working families and
strengthen our economy
strengthen in the long run these
investments are critical
and as the plans i put forward tackle
our climate crisis
which are broad and deep i'm going to
fight to see them enacted
and signed into law we have a chance to
seize this economic momentum
of the first months of my administration
not just to build back but as i've been
saying
build back better this is much
already this much is already clear we're
on track and we're on the right track
our plan is working and we're not going
to let up now
so i want to thank everyone wish you all
a happy
4th of july are going to be able to go
to ball games you're going to be able to
sit in stadiums
you're going to be able to be with your
families and backyard barbecues as we
hoped
and we're going to make more progress so
god bless america may god protect our
troops
talk to us about afghanistan is the
drawdown going to be done
in the next few days no
no no we're on we're on track exactly
as to where we expect it to be but we
just i wanted to make sure there was
enough
quote running room that we could get
wouldn't be able to do it all to
september there'll still be some
four forces left but it's a rational
draw down with our allies and it's
making
so there's nothing unusual about it are
you worried that the afghan government
might fall i mean we're hearing about
the taliban taking more and more
districts
look we're in that war for 20 years
20 years and uh i think i met with
the afghan government here in the white
house in the oval
i think they have the capacity to be
able to sustain
the government they're going to have to
be down the road more negotiations i
suspect
but i am i am
concerned that they deal with the
internal issues that they have to be
able to generate the kind of support
they need nationwide
to maintain the government on
afghanistan
if there is evidence that kabul is is
threatened when some of the intelligence
reports have suggested
it could be in six months or thereabouts
do you think you've got the capability
to help provide
any kind of air support military support
to them to
to keep the capital safe even if the u.s
troops are obviously fully out but
we have uh worked out an overhaul rising
capacity
that we can be value added but the
afghans are going to have to be able to
do it themselves with the air force they
have
what you're helping to maintain
i'm not going to answer any more a quick
question in afghanistan look
fourth of july i'm concerned that you
guys are asking me questions that i'll
answer next week but on this the holiday
weekend i'm going to celebrate it
there's great things happening
economy has grown faster than any time
in 40 years we've got a record number of
new jobs covades are down 90
wages are up faster than any time in 15
years
we're bringing out our bringing our
troops home we have all across america
people are going to ball games and
doing good things this is a good i'll be
allies for all your negative questions
not negative
you're a legitimate question are you
concerned that
there is a potential this weekend in
places where vaccination levels are not
particularly high
that there will be a new coved outbreaks
in various regions i am
concerned that people who have not
gotten vaccinated
have the capacity to
catch the variant and spread the variant
to other people who have not been
vaccinated
i am not concerned there's going to be a
major outbreak in other words that we're
going to have
another epidemic nationwide but i'm
concerned
lies will be lost and i was even reading
today there's some speculation
some judgment is coming out that you may
be able to even communicate
the vaccine of the uh the uh
um the new uh variant to your pets
so i say not not totally facetiously for
those
of you who haven't been vaccinated
because you don't you don't you don't
think it's
you you want to go through it it doesn't
hurt it's accessible
it's free it's available and not only
don't think about yourself think about
your family
think about those around you that's what
we should be thinking about
today the fourth of july to this year is
different than the fourth of july last
year
and it's gonna be better next year thank
you all do you think that congress will
enact your plans are you confident that
you're gonna get it done
oh come on guys mike have you ever been
confident about
anything with guaranteed who wants to
put money on
anything that congress is going to do
look folks this is a process
this is a process i love you guys but
it's a process and i don't know you want
me to say yes
i'm absolutely certain well are you
absolutely certain this new commission
is going to
work uh you know investigating what
happened on the sixth
are you guys confident that the
republicans going to participate
look all i know only and i know what to
do and i really mean this
is do my best to lay out what i think
the country has to do
try to be as persuasive as i can and
hope and thus far
uh you know it's uh you know it seems to
be working a little bit
thank you mr president do you think it's
fair that the olympic launcher
you